he lives we all thought merrick garland
was gone
after cocaine mitch kept him off the
supreme court
but merrick garland is back long after
the left
mourned his loss the democrats rent
their garments and gnashed their teeth
merrick garland is back he is joe
biden's nominee for attorney general
and i actually don't mind this
nomination all that much
relative to some of the other picks
because one it's kind of funny merrick
garland became this meme
after he was nominated to the court and
now he's back it'd be sort of like if
harambe came back to that zoo you know
everyone would kind of get a kick out of
that but the other reason the more
substantive reason why i wasn't so upset
about garland is
he was the most moderate of the joe
biden
prominent nominees so i thought okay we
can breathe a sigh of release at least
he's not going
with some crazy left winger for attorney
general and then
merrick garland testified on capitol
hill he was grilled
by a bunch of senators on his views
turns out he's not
all that moderate here is josh hawley
republican senator
asking a very simple question merrick
garland will you
continue to enforce our southern border
and the answer
pretty weak stuff do you believe that
illegal entry
at america's border should remain a
crime well i haven't thought about uh
that question uh uh i just haven't
thought about that question i
i think you know the the president has
uh
made clear that we are a country of uh
with the borders and with the concern
about national security
um i don't know of a proposal to uh
decriminalize but still make it uh
unlawful to enter i just don't know the
answer to that question i haven't
thought about it
will you continue to prosecute on
unlawful
border crossings well this is again a
question of allocation of resources
um we will uh the department uh
will uh prevent unlawful
uh crossing i i have to admit i just
don't
unders know exactly what the conditions
are and how this is uh
done uh um i just know it doesn't uh uh
uh well simple question merrick will you
enforce the law at the border well uh uh
uh uh oh boy i'm michael knowles it's
the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from
july 24 pictures who says the woke left
says be less white me acts more black
the woke left says hey how racist of you
to appropriate their culture yes
this is the uh paradox here too with the
the be
less white campaign that uh you saw from
some of these
corporations i was associated with
coca-cola coca-cola was kind of not
denying it it's part of robin d'angelo's
broader
and anti-racist curriculum that a lot of
corporations
are buying into and when you say be less
white
first of all it's not pot you can't you
know you're not going to demyelinate
your skin
but even if you lose your own culture as
a white person
then what do you do the only thing you
have to have some kind of culture you
have to have certain behaviors and
matters of speaking and things like that
so the only thing you can do
is take on the attributes of other
cultures but then the minute you do that
you're accused of cultural appropriation
so there
is no win you are damned if you do and
damned
if you don't what crazy times don't you
wish you could think back on all those
wonderful halcyon days going by when
things are more normal well you can
with legacy box legacy box is an
ingenious mail-in service to have
all of your irreplaceable moments
trapped on videotapes camcorder tapes
film reels and pictures
converted to dvd or digital to preserve
them home movies can transport us back
to
unforgettable times well i hope you
don't forget them the way that you can
not forget them is by preserving them i
will
warn you i i dragged my feet i didn't
send all my stuff into legacy box right
away
even though i knew i'd been told by
friends of mine ben had had legacy box
on the show for a while
i'd been told it was great i hadn't done
it
and i lost a lot of article or a lot of
photos rather of a
family member of mine who had passed
luckily i found some more pictures
immediately sent them to legacy box it's
so
simple it's so easy they send back the
physical media to you and they send it
back digitized it's
just magnificent get started preserving
your pass today go to legacybox.com
knowles to get an incredible 40 off your
first order buy today
to take advantage of this exclusive
offer send it in when you're ready
go to legacy box dot com slash knowles
and save 40 while supplies last
head on over to legacy box right now
that testimony that merrick garland
gave to josh hawley was was
even worse i think than many people
realize because
i think the way most people analyze that
is they say okay merrick garland he's
this very
serious procedure-focused lawyer who's
nitpicking all the minor details and he
doesn't want to give a flippant answer
to anything
sure maybe the first question might lead
you to think that
he says hey are are you going to
continue to enforce the law at the
border
he says well uh well and i don't know
that there's a way that you could
there's no proposal to keep the
the border secure but then not enforce
the law and this and he's getting
into all this minutia then he says sort
of platitudes like
joe biden believes this is a country
with a border
oh he believes it's a country all
countries have borders
so the grand brave courageous statement
from joe biden is america is still a
country at least for now
but then the reason that i don't think
you can just
chalk this up to merrick garland is
trying to be really precise
is when hawley pushes him on it's a
simple question it's illegal to
and it's illegal by definition to enter
the country illegally will you continue
to enforce the law
merrick garland changes his approach so
he doesn't just say well what do you
mean by illegal and listen
he then says well that would be a matter
of allocating resources it would be a
question of where we want to put our
resources
so he's totally changing his answer he's
saying well
uh you caught me josh hawley uh probably
not
probably i'm not going to enforce the
law
uh really bad stuff if this is the most
moderate guy
garland is catching probably most flack
right now
for saying that refusing to
acknowledge that burning down federal
buildings is
domestic terrorism i actually think here
merrick garland is showing a kind of
restraint i actually think conservatives
shouldn't totally attack him
for his answer though it didn't sound
all too great yesterday when he gave
it let me ask you about assaults
on federal property in places other than
washington d.c portland for instance
seattle do you regard assaults on
federal courthouses or other federal
property as acts of domestic
extremism domestic terrorism well
a senator my own definition which is
about the same as the statutory
definition
is uh the use of violence or threats of
violence
uh an attempt to disrupt democratic
processes
so an attack on a
courthouse while in operation trying to
prevent
judges from actually deciding cases that
plainly
is domestic
uh extremism um um um uh
domestic uh terrorism um an attack
simply on a government property at night
or any other kind of
circumstances is a clear crime and a
serious one and should be punished
i don't mean i don't know enough about
the facts of the example you're talking
about but
that's where i draw the line one one is
both
are uh criminal um but one
is uh a core attack on our democratic
institutions so
this answer filled with garland's usual
ums and awes and hmms and stammering
is a little bit weak in that he's
conflating extremism which is a very
vague
term that can really mean anything you
want it to with terrorism which is a
much more specific term
but i actually don't think that burning
down a federal courthouse for instance
is necessarily
terrorism and the reason for that is
terrorism traditionally defined
is specifically the use of violence
against
civilians for the purpose of achieving
political ends
and this is why if you attack a
political target you know a government
target that is different than attacking
an elementary school those are those are
different things both very bad you know
both should be discouraged but
we don't want the definition of
terrorism to become
overly broad just as has happened with
extremism
now the reason this is a bad answer from
garland is it
they'll take away technical details
aside and conservatives should pay
attention to the details but the
takeaway is he's not going to go after
groups like blm
for burning down courthouses and federal
buildings and other sort of government
buildings and that's
that's too bad but still i i actually
think he's getting too much flack for
that answer
a much more radical answer even than the
extremism terrorism answer that garland
gave
and this this is like sort of the third
and final point maybe it's worth
considering
republicans trying to vote against him i
don't think there's any way to stop this
garland nomination
i think we already we already stopped
the main garland nomination but
he gave an answer on the transgender
question
that to my mind shows he is basically
unfit for this job
he was asked a simple question is it
right and just and lawful for
girls to have to compete against boys
in other words does the law
say that boys can just define themselves
and girls for the purposes of say
playing
women's sports for the purposes of going
into the girls bathroom this is
not a difficult question but merrick
garland seems to think that it is
in my last 20 seconds i'm going to ask
you if you agree with this statement
uh allowing and i'm not suggesting the
answer one way or the other i just want
to know what you believe
allowing biological males to compete in
an
all-female sport deprives women of the
opportunity to participate fully and
fairly in sports
and is fundamentally unfair to female
athletes
this is a very difficult societal
question that you're asking here i know
what underlies no but you're going to be
attorney general oh but
uh i may not be the one who has to make
policy decisions like that but it's not
that i'm adverse to it look i think
every
human being should be treated with
dignity and respect
and that's an overriding sense of my own
character but an overriding sense of
what the law
requires this the particular
question of how title ix applies in
schools is one and in light of the
bosniak case
which i know you're very familiar with
is something that i would have to look
at
when i have a chance to do that and
there it is there is the answer
the boss stock case is the case that uh
thanks to our good friend neil gorsuch
uh the boss
who was you know the ostensibly
conservative judge who totally
totally broke with conservatives and
redefined
uh sex as gender identity in that case
i'm oversimplifying a little bit but
that's that's the takeaway of it
if garland is saying in light of boss
stock i'd have to revisit it what he's
saying is yeah boys can compete against
girls and girls can't really say
anything about it
when when he says well this is one of
the most difficult
societal questions no it's not
it's a very simple question can can men
magically become women
that's that's the question that's what
it boils down to can men magically
become women
and is there therefore no difference
really no substantial difference between
men and women
simple question merrick garland doesn't
want to answer it he can answer it but
he doesn't want to answer it because his
answer is radical
when he says look i don't know if i'm
gonna be making policy on this
if you're the attorney general of the
united states this is one of the most
hotly
debated issues and you are going to have
to interpret
specifically this kind of law then
it is not only important that you know
the answer to that question
but it is your job so if you're going to
in this sort of cowardly way say well i
don't know that i'll have any of course
you will do you not even know what your
job is
of course you will but he he doesn't
want to say and then he comes out with
that very courageous
statement look my guiding principle is i
think people should be treated with
dignity and respect
oh wow oh my gosh that's almost as brave
as joe biden saying
i believe the nation should still have
borders for now
yeah sure buddy oh great dignity respect
we up we all agree on that
but is it your view that we should force
little girls to compete against
grown men grown i mean physically grown
i suppose they're the same age but much
more grown out they're bigger they're
stronger they're faster because men are
different than women and lose their
scholarships and lose their trophies
and but by that same principle have to
go to the men's changing room in the
public pool or rather have men go into
their change room in the public pool
which destroys the entire concept of
men's and women's changing rooms
have to use the bathroom with men what
what is your answer that actually is a
radical question
and sadly i think he gave us our answer
if you want
simple answers to complex questions head
on over to rockauto.com
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low and the same for
professionals
and do-it-yourselfers why would you
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts
the rockauto.com catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle and choose the brands
specifications and prices that you
prefer fabulous
selection and you won't get caught in
this very embarrassing
situation that i sometimes could find
myself in which is
you go into the brick and mortar auto
parts store and they ask you
all this all these questions about your
car and you don't know anything and then
you know they go in the back they don't
have the part they order it online
probably from rockauto.com
then they charge you twice as much why
would you do that when the rockoto.com
catalog is so simple to navigate even i
can do it
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
and then write knowles k-n-w-l-e-s
in there how did you hear about us box
so that they know
we sent you speaking of supreme court
nominees i guess in this case of
successful supreme court nominees unlike
mayor garland who was an unsuccessful
supreme court nominee
justice thomas is the last tough guy
left in america
the last guy with really rock-ribbed
moral vision
honorable mentions to alito here and i
suppose even gorsuch even though i still
haven't forgiven gorsuch for that
transgender decision
the supreme court was asked to hear a
case
the final case of the 2020 election
regarding
mail-in ballots in pennsylvania there
were lots of questions about mail-in
ballots in pennsylvania
because probably most importantly the
supreme court or i'm sorry the
constitution of pennsylvania prohibits
the use
of these widespread mail-in ballots that
we saw in the 2020 election
the pennsylvania supreme court in a very
politically motivated decision just
chose to ignore that part of the
constitution
the u.s supreme court didn't want to
hear about it then there was this issue
of mail-in ballots coming in
after election day whether or not that
those can be
those can be counted supreme court
actually was sort of willing to weigh in
on that but now
they're not willing to hear the case
regarding the validity of these ballots
sadly you got all the libs voting not to
hear the case
you also have john roberts but i guess i
repeat myself
you also have amy barrett voted not to
hear this case
you also have brett kavanaugh voted not
to hear this case
we fought real hard to get brett
kavanaugh that seat we fought real hard
to send merrick garland into political
irrelevance at least for a few years
and they went squishy they went squishy
on what should be a very simple
answer now thomas alito and gorsuch
did think that the court should weigh in
on this matter
thomas most vigorously so thomas
in his dissent said something very
important
and it's important for not just this
election
because the court generally speaking
they did say we don't think that these
votes would have changed the results of
the 2020 election
however they could have very serious
impact in the future
and so we need to we need to take a look
at them
thomas said something here that
i have been saying since the 2020
election
actually i have argued with many
conservatives on this point since the
2020 election
and thomas you know how much i hate to
say i told you so thomas
seems to be on my side of this question
thomas wrote and actually a little
footnote in the case he says
we are fortunate that many of the cases
we have seen alleged only
improper rule changes not fraud but that
observation provides only small comfort
an election free from strong evidence of
systemic fraud
is not alone sufficient for election
confidence also important is the
assurance that fraud will not go
undetected this line i want you to
highlight this
i don't know how you're going to
highlight it in the air as you're
listening to this
in a podcast on the radio or on youtube
but but make note of this line
an election free from strong evidence of
systemic fraud is not alone sufficient
for election confidence
when some of my friends on the right
in the days after the 2020 election were
demanding they said we need the evidence
we need the evidence we need the
evidence i
agreed with them i said yeah you know
the trump team obviously needs to make
the case in court and they're not going
to be able to make the case if they
don't have evidence
however this election looks pretty
crooked to me folks it seems
like there was a lot of irregularity
going on and what some of my friends
even on the right would say
is if you can't provide all of the
evidence
then we must conclude that the election
was totally fine and there were no
questions it was absolutely legit
and i said no that's not true you don't
get to
in the weeks and months before the
election change practically all the
rules all of the important rules
surrounding election integrity
you don't get to violate the state
constitution for goodness sakes in
pennsylvania
to give an advantage to democrats you
don't get to
extend election day into election month
thereby diminishing election integrity
and making it more vulnerable to fraud
you don't get to extend the counting of
the ballots you don't get to do all
these things
that cut at the heart of election
integrity and then tell me the burden is
entirely on me to prove that there was
some shenanigans going on
i'm seeing what you're doing you're
taking away all of the safeguards
therefore it is absolutely my right to
raise questions
i it is absolutely my right to not have
much confidence in this electoral
process that's what
thomas is saying right here justice
thomas
the man the the man left on the supreme
court
i like some of the other guys too
depending on the day especially elito
but thomas thomas is
one of the most clear-eyed conservatives
in the entire country
he's making exactly the same point and i
don't think that there is anything
illegitimate or wrong or shameful
about pointing out that when you get rid
of a lot of the election integrity
measures
people are going to lose some confidence
in the election speaking of frauds
dr fauci dr fauci is back actually
speaking of frauds and things that i
hate to say i told you so about
dr fauci is back he's uh he's really
losing his appeal i think by the minute
even among
some people who are more in the center
and maybe even on the left dr fauci
of 15 days to slow the spread fame is
telling us that we
will probably need to wear masks even
after the vaccine after this after that
until 2022. why do you think americans
might have to wear masks into 2022
you know because it depends on the low
on the level of
of of of dynamics of virus that's in the
community and that's really important
because that gets back to something
again that you said if you see the level
coming down really really very low i
wanted to keep going down
to a baseline that's so low that there's
virtually no threat
or not no it'll never be zero but a
minimum minimal threat
that you will be exposed to someone who
is infected
so if you combine getting most of the
people in the country vaccinated
with getting the level of virus in the
community
very very low then i believe you're
going to be able to say you know
for the most part we don't necessarily
have to wear mass
so i love this the cnn lady is giving me
a lot of respect for i don't even know
her name but i
i am getting some respect for her
because she is pushing back on pouchy
she says well hold on
we get the vaccine we get why do we have
to do this because well you see because
i want the
virus to get down to below zero i want
there to be negative virus
in the world so that of course it can
never be negative virus it can never be
zero so you're always going to need good
old dr fauci
dr fouchy's always going to have to tell
you what to do but
uh we'll get a very very very low and
then we'll eliminate gems and lives in
utopia
that's what i want say uh how about we
just you know
we just take off the masks then if
that's your argument let's just take it
off
this is the sort of thing
that the people who said many of my
friends many
conservative friends said from the
beginning they said
just wear the mask it's not a big deal
and i have said basically since the very
beginning
the masks are not just dumb
but really bad as a political matter
for all of the various left-wing censors
out here
i i suppose i need to clarify i'm not
talking about
the science because this isn't really
about the science this is about the
politics
as a political matter what the people
who believe just wear the mask it's not
a big deal what they thought was
well if we all wear the masks we can go
back to normal but the opposite is true
every minute that we wear the masks
is is more likely to extend the length
of this whole lock down this epidemic
this social upheaval
because the masks are not a source of
comfort the masks are a sign
a visual sign and a very blatant one to
everybody
that we are in the midst of something
really really crazy
and probably pretty dangerous because we
haven't done this before as a society
we've never mandated mandated that we
all just put filthy cloth over our
mouths wherever we go and muzzle
ourselves outdoors indoors
anywhere you go so it it doesn't serve
the purpose
that the people who said oh it's not a
big deal just do it we'll get back to
normal
doesn't serve the purpose that they
thought it would as
long as we are wearing the masks dr
fauci is in control
because the masks are the sign that
we're amid the
historic unprecedented public health
crisis and all we can do is empower dr
fauci our brilliant wonderful leader who
is venerated as an icon
in in many parts of the left
there's dr fauci day now on
christmas eve in washington dc do you
remember that the mayor named it dr
fauci day
didn't acknowledge uh you know this is
christmas eve isn't that a little is it
kind of a weird liturgical calendar
and fouchy himself sort of admits it we
want to get that number low low low
but it's never totally gone and dr fauci
has never totally gone either as long as
we empower him in this way
and as long as we radically change our
behavior and our appearance i mean the
most intimate
kind of decisions that we make about how
we comport ourselves in the world
as long as we entirely defer to him on
that that
little dude is in control
you know we are going to be hearing
quite a lot about the authoritarian left
on the march from mr shapiro coming up
after this
so go be sure to check that out also we
are going to be having our backstage
tomorrow
february 24th it's gonna be a ton of fun
there's gonna be a lot of stogies
there's gonna be a lot of drinks it's
gonna be very very enjoyable
and we have a new show coming out this
friday featuring our very own
bench bureau there are many narratives
going on around hot
topic issues it is very difficult to
keep track of all the newest
controversies and
non-traverses that the left pretends to
be offended by which is why you're going
to want to tune in to debunked to see
ben expose leftist fallacies in 15
minutes or less
this show will be available exclusively
to daily wire members
so if you're not already a member go to
dailywire.com subscribe
use code debunked to get 25 off
the reasons to join daily wire keep on
piling up i am getting crushed by them
it is an avalanche of reasons head on
over use code debunked for 25 off today
head to dailywire.com we'll be right
back with a lot more
i read a headline the other day
headlines said
boy scouts welcomes first class of
girl eagle scouts my first thought was
uh no they didn't they they didn't the
boy scouts did not
welcome the first class of of girl
eagle scouts now
i know that there is an organization
called the boy scouts
and i know that the boy scouts now lets
in
girls and i know that there's a
designation called the eagle scouts and
i know that the eagle scouts now have
some girls
in it but it is not
possible for the boy scouts
to have girls in the scouts because the
boy scouts
are the boy scouts and the minute they
let in a girl
they cease to be the boy scouts
they might pretend to be the boy scouts
but they are not
they it is not possible going back to
our friend old old uncle aristotle as we
call him around these parts
you cannot simultaneously have a thing
and the opposite of the thing and have
them
be true at the same time the boy scouts
can only have boys in them i i can't
believe that we have to spend time
saying this
but i think the reason we have to say
this
is because we live in a culture that's
very open
and very liberal and very inclusive
and there are some benefits of this but
it can be taken to
absurdities and even conservatives
embrace all this kind of language we're
open-minded you know i'm a free speech
absolutist
i yeah man i don't i don't want any sort
of exclusion or censorship whatsoever
you you need exclusion
for societies to make sense i'm not
saying
unjust exclusion i don't want that but
you do need
just exclusion for instance the men's
bathroom
must exclude women simply for it to be
the men's bathroom it has to exclude
women
same thing is true of the women's
bathroom if the women's bathroom is
open and liberal and inclusive of men
then it hasn't become an inclusive open
liberal women's bathroom it just stopped
being the women's bathroom
the same thing is true of the boy scouts
if the boy scouts in the name of
liberality and openness
and inclusion and diversity accepts
women you haven't
created this more open boy scouts you've
just abolished
the boy scouts there's been a lot of
talk about
norm normal when are we going to get
back to normal
we're wearing masks we're not seeing our
grandparents we're not having
thanksgiving dinner
when are we going to get back to normal
norms define
normal we are we are edging day by day
by day that we let this nonsense go
on day by day by day that we wear the
stupid masks we are creating
a new normal it is it is now
normal to wear the masks and it's
abnormal not to wear the masks
and you're you can't have a society
that's free of norms
there's no such thing i think we like to
fool ourselves of that the left
really pushes this idea that you don't
need any norms nothing there's nothing
that we ought to do
there's you know we just do whatever you
want as long as it doesn't hurt anybody
else maybe
and the right has adopted a lot of that
same language
oh man i don't care what you do is it
doesn't affect me live and let live man
norms are inevitable norms are
inevitable
if if you are i think a lot of us want
to pretend that
oh man just who cares if the boy scouts
let some girls down who you know it's
not
such a minor issue well i mean it's it
is and it isn't
it's a minor issue in that i'm not a
member of the boy scouts and i have no
intention of sending my son to the boy
scouts
but it's a big issue in that we as a
society are now saying you're not
allowed to have the boy scouts you're
just
destroying those sorts of things
and if you follow this gender ideology
to its logical conclusion not only do
you get rid of the bathrooms and the
girls sports you get rid of girls
schools
you get rid of sororities you get rid of
fraternities you get rid of
anything that makes any distinction
between men and women
i don't know about you i find the
distinction between men and women to be
one of the things that gives
life its uh joy you know one of
one of the things that makes this world
kind of nice that men and women are
different i like women you know it's
sort of
that men are from morris women are from
venus that's kind of one of the
playful aspects of the world the
complementarity between the sexes
but we are now being told you can't have
that and if you want a society that does
still have that you have to stand up for
that
and that's an exclusive claim truth
claims tend to be exclusive
but the gender ideology is marching
onward my friend ryan anderson ryan t
anderson at the ethics and public policy
center he was with the heritage
foundation for a long time
he wrote a book with i think the
greatest title i've i've ever read on a
book
the title is when harry became sally
responding to the transgender moment
just uh tremendous that guy could have
scribbled and crayon in between the
covers he still would have sold a bunch
of copies
so very very enjoyable book i highly
recommend it
amazon took it down amazon took
down when harry became sally because i
don't because it's politically incorrect
it's hateful it's bigoted you've got
one of the most respected sort of public
scholars
in the entire mainstream conservative
movement ryan t
anderson puts out this you know very
academic work on transgenderism
taken down for hate speech meanwhile
i just read from ryan's twitter account
apple ibooks is taking it down now you
can't download it
it's going to be banned i have a book by
the way i may have mentioned this
coming out on this very topic why
conservatives have gotten this issue
so wrong why every attempt that they've
made to fight political correctness has
actually
helped advance political correctness
over the last several decades
i have this book coming out it's called
speechless controlling words controlling
minds it is currently up on amazon
i don't think it's going to stay up on
amazon i think that
when when the left understands the
thesis of this book
and some of the arguments that are made
in the book i think they are going to
take it down so if you want to get it i
would
urge you to pre-order it now because i
really
i'm i'm not just selling books though i
would like to do that too but i don't
know if they're going to take down
ryan's book
i can't imagine what the future is for
my book or even many other conservative
books that dare to talk about anything
other than you know cutting taxes or
something that dare to talk about any
cultural issue and what we're really
talking about here is cancel culture
because what you're hearing from some of
the squishes
who can call themselves conservatives
but also from the left is
it's not cancelled culture to take down
ryan's book we don't like that book it's
amazon has no obligation or apple has no
obligation to host a book that they
disagree with
come on they're private companies it's a
free market right
that's not cancel culture
i have said uh basically from the
beginning of this whole thing this whole
show is basically just i hate to say i
told you so
from the beginning of this whole thing i
have said that i don't think
cancel culture is a particularly precise
or helpful term
because if it falls into the classic
trap of political correctness which is
political correctness is the instrument
by which the left
attacks traditional standards it's just
an attack it's just a criticism you've
heard of critical theory
it's like that it just criticizes and
criticizes and criticizes
and tries to tear down the old
traditional order
then conservatives respond to that
either by acquiescing and saying okay
well i'll go along you know what's the
big deal right sort of the thing on
masks
okay no big deal i'll just go along or
the other way conservatives react is
they say hey
i oppose any kind of standards i oppose
any kind of censorship
i oppose any kind of guard rails on our
society
so i'm against cancel culture
and then either way the left wins
because now nobody is defending the old
traditional
moral standards i i've
mentioned this before you know sometimes
you see this on left wing
twitter accounts and things they'll send
these memes around they'll it'll be a
picture of joe mccarthy and they'll say
you know conservatives were doing cancel
culture before it was cool conservatives
originated canceled culture and there's
some truth to that mccarthyism
which until very recently was defended
by all the mainstream conservatives
uh the idea that you could root out
communists who are working for foreign
governments who are seeking to subvert
your country it's not a particularly
controversial
point of view though it's been revised
through
various political activists to say that
it would be that's that's not
wild that's not extraordinary that's
been true since the beginning of the
country we've always had laws against
sedition we've always had laws against
fraud we've always had laws against
obscenity though they're not really
enforced much these days they were still
being enforced even
a dozen years ago we still have
or i suppose now now going on 14 years
ago when george bush jailed a
pornographer because he
because the pornography was so obscene
there are always constraints
on language and speech do you think that
if some guy walks into your office
he's got a nazi armband on he walks up
to the water cooler and starts screaming
zig heil
do you think that guy has a right to
keep his job
do you think that if he were fired for
that that would be cancel culture no of
course you
you absolutely agree as we all do that
private associations and businesses and
even whole societies
have the right to determine their
standards and their norms
just by definition every society does
that so
i don't use the term cancer culture
cancer when i use it
when i when i invoke that i'm referring
to a very specific thing which is what
we see going on right now
it's when the left targets conservatives
for saying perfectly reasonable things
the difference between my definition of
cancel culture and the kind of
abstract version is i'm talking about a
real thing that's actually happening
i'm describing a discrete specific
phenomenon
and the substance of that it's not just
the form that matters it's not just that
people are being censored or ostracized
it's the substance what are they being
censored for
what are they being ostracized for
if if some guy has the the armband on
and he says zig hile at the water cooler
then i don't think it's wrong to
ostracize him from the company
but if that if another guy walks up to
the water cooler and he's got an
american flag and he says i'm a yankee
doodle dandy and he gets fired for that
that i am against that is the sort of
cancel culture that we're seeing right
now
people saying perfectly mainstream
patriotic traditional american things
and having their lives ruined for that
that but the substance there
really matters and this brings us to
cpac the conservative political action
conference has been going on for a long
time the american conservative union
uh puts it on it's always a very fun
event i went last year where we did a
verdict episode with
ted cruz a lot of i've been going for
years and years and i think i went to my
first cpac ten years ago
cpac's title this year is america
uncanceled
fighting back against cancel culture and
uh fine fair enough
but they just found out that one of
their speakers this guy uh
young pharaoh who i don't know what he
does
but i don't know he's like some pop
culture guy or something
young pharaoh has said some very
offensive things about jews
and other people so what does cpac do
they cancel them from their roster now
cpac is being called hypocrites because
they're indulging in cancer culture
i don't think cpac is being hypocritical
at all i think it is the
shallowest stupidest read of the term
cancel culture
to suggest that you can never have any
standards at all
i think it is that that kind of a
shallow interpretation
that has allowed political correctness
to advance
for decades and decades and actually if
you
believe the argument of my book it's
been advancing for about a century
there is nothing conservative about
removing all the guard rails think about
it like a country
think about it just like a country a
country needs borders that was that was
what
merrick garland finally acknowledged
that joe biden he says look
he believes that it's a country that has
borders all countries have borders and
what borders mean is
some people are in and some people are
out
a certain area defines what the country
is and things outside that area
that's not the country the same thing is
true in our philosophy
do you think if cpac invited someone to
speak forget about you know
anti-jewish comments let's make it even
more basic than that
some guy gets invited to speak at cpac
and then in between the time he gets
invited in the time he speaks
he becomes a liberal democrat and he
wants to give a speech on how great aoc
is
and how he can't wait to vote for joe
biden's reelection or better yet kamala
harris
do you think cpac has an obligation
you know in its opposition to cancel
culture and obligation to put that guy
on stage
no of course not if anything cpac has an
obligation to take that guy off the
roster
because this is the conservative
political action conference and
conservatism
stands for something we're debating what
that stands for
but but we we absolutely must define it
and actually
the unwillingness the cowardly
unwillingness to define
what conservatives stand for is what has
made us lose
many many many times over the past
several decades
president trump one of the few
republicans to win
in recent years though then he sadly is
no longer president but he did win in
2016.
trump is going to speak at cpac and the
reports are
that president trump is going to speak
on the future of the gop
there are some reports that he's going
to say he's the presumptive nominee
in 2024. i don't know they might just be
floating that just to get some buzz or
some publicity or something
but it does seem likely that he's going
to be speaking on the future of the gop
what is the future of the gop
i don't know we're going to be debating
that obviously i have my preferences
other people have other preferences
but the one thing i know that it's not
going to be if the gop has a
future at all is the old gop of the last
20 years
it's not going to be that because that
gop
doesn't win any battles even when they
win elections they don't win any
substantive battles
you lose all the important issues you
lose
you you lose every important issue up to
and including the
freaking girls bathroom you couldn't
even conserve that
whatever the future of the gop is
whatever the future of conservatism is
it's going to have to
conserve something which brings us
to an article in reason
i just read an article in reason
magazine reason
is the sort of libertarian website and
magazine
and i have great respect for
many libertarians i am not myself a
libertarian but i have respect for many
libertarians but i don't have respect
for libertines there's there should be a
difference between libertarianism and
libertinism but increasingly
there really is not the article in
reason is
is there a future for fusionism
fusionism refers to the kind of
conservative coalition that cropped up
after world war ii
and defined the cold war and it was put
together by guys like william f buckley
jr
and ronald reagan and national review
and god and men at yale and there's all
this sort of movement and buckley is
kind of the central figure
now
what what i actually think it's worth
reading this reason article even though
they're
wrong in their conclusion but they say
the fall of the ussr meant the collapse
of the common foe that had sustained the
fusionist partnership
of the kind of traditional conservatives
and the libertarians and the warhawks
it was able to trundle on for a while
powered by a reservoir of goodwill but
it has
long been running on fumes in the last
few years the alliance's inherent
tensions have come to a head
it's increasingly common to hear that
whatever value there may have been in
cooperation during the 50s 60s 70s and
80s
the era of good conservative feelings is
over i agree with that that's a good
take
for many libertarians this is where it
goes off the rails for many libertarians
the trump years revealed
their traditionalist allies to be
hypocrites and opportunists
all too willing to sell out the ideals
of fusionism
in service of an aspiring dictator okay
here we go am i reading
what is this is this cnn that i'm
reading what it would the
libertarians now are going to sound like
msnbc conservatives have commenced a
not-so-slow descent toward
authoritarianism uh if that word could
be struck forever from the english
language
i would i would pass a law to do it in
my authoritarian
abilities i it's what a stupid word it's
basically a meaningless word
and they're not so slow to send toward
authoritarianism some in this group
suggest
for if the philosophy of liberty is to
have a future it must involve building
bridges to the left
not to the right and there it is russell
kirk one of the great conservative
writers and thinkers of the 20th century
long warned that the alliance between
libertarians and conservatives never
made any sense
that conservatives should be very wary
of that because ultimately the
libertarians were going to break to the
left
and the many many people who i think
call themselves libertarian but they're
not really
they wouldn't agree with reason magazine
you know they're really more
conservative than all that
they're going to have to pick a side
they're either going to have to go to
the left
and sound like msnbc like reason
magazine here or they're going to have
to go
and be conservative what what they
really misunderstand here
is they could change one word in this
article and it would make sense if they
changed it to
if the philosophy of licentiousness is
to have a future
it must involve building bridges to the
left not the right but liberty and
licentiousness are very different things
lord acton a man revered by
true libertarians by libertarians many
many
decades and longer what he said was
liberty is not as many people commonly
think it is
the ability to do whatever you want and
pursue your appetites however you end
your desires however you want
liberty is the right to do what you
ought
i know this is a shocking statement for
a lot of people liberty
freedom is not just the ability to do
whatever we want because the thing is if
you just pursue your base passions all
the time
then you're going to lose your liberty
if you let's say you know
i i really want heroin you're going to
go out and shoot up a bunch of heroin
and you say oh man i've never been more
free
do you think heroin addicts have a whole
lot of liberty do you think they're the
freest people no they're slaves
they're slaves to their appetites which
gets to the
classical conservative understanding of
liberty
the man who sins is a slave to sin we
need liberal education to make sense of
our liberty to tame our base passions to
tame our vices
to practice virtue to uh
develop our cultivate our reason
cultivate our will control our will
then we can be really free this is what
all the founding fathers believed
and the more libertine camp
that has found itself on the right that
uh
that they no longer like that now i
don't think
as some people on the right have said
some conservatives said we need to you
know boot out all the libertarians or
anything i think that's a losing battle
you know i think that politics is the
art of inclusion
you've got to bring people in if you
want a winning coalition
so i think people who say i'm a
libertarian you know and they wave their
gadsden flag
and they say darn it i stand for the
american tradition of liberty yeah those
guys
obviously those are conservatives those
are those are people who i
i think make common cause with us but
there's another type of
libertarian you know the type i'm
talking about if you've ever spent any
time around
a college campus or even high school i
guess you
you know those libertarians where the
most important political issue to them
is legalizing pot you know they forget
about
you know foreign policy immigration
abortion
uh any sort of economic policy
trade no forget about that the most
important thing is that everyone gets to
smoke
the devil's lettuce you know the sin
spinach those guys
i don't think they really have a future
on the right i don't think there's
there's nothing
really conservative about them their
understanding of liberty is totally
wrong i mean those are the kind of guys
i think
that reason magazine is talking about
right now
but the thing reason gets right that i
think
trump is getting right in giving the
speech at cpac that
all of us are intuiting is that whatever
was meant by conservatism in
the 20th century up till the end of the
cold war that was great that worked that
defeated the soviet union
and then whatever was meant after that
didn't really make a whole lot of sense
and when you look back on the bush years
do you really think like oh yes that was
the
triumph of conservative values in
america uh no
is mostly a period of decline and loss
of things that we cherish so whatever is
going to come next it's going to be
different
than what it was in the past
for for too long now i think
conservatism has been cancelled
to use a fattish and sort of stupid word
conservatism has been cancelled
by people who want to make conservatism
basically the same thing as liberalism
and not let us defend any of the things
we want to defend and not let us
preserve
anything resembling the american way of
life
we're barely allowed to go outside
anymore and when we go outside we have
to listen to some technic rat egghead
tell us what to wear even on our faces
no if we're to
if we're going to be conservatives in
the future we're we're going to have to
conserve the the traditions and the way
of life
that we've long cherished in this
country i'm michael knowles the michael
knowles show
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright dailywire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show democratic congress
people seek to purge
media outlets they don't like plus
president biden holds an empathetic
commemorative event for 500 000
americans who died of covet in the media
go gaga that's today on the ben shapiro
show give it a listen